[Musique]
un bel accueil pour la ministre de
l'outre-mer venu conclure ce forum
d'affaires international de la
transformation numérique
le premier forum business d'affaires
internationale créée à la réunion c'est
un forum ont vraiment on a pu réunir qui
ont 15 pays d'afrique cette année on
veut vraiment montrer que la réunion a
une place à jouer sur la carte
internationale
on a les capacités et des compétences
dans la filière numérique réunionnaise
mais aussi dans les autres filières
économiques la france ultramarine est le
meilleur atout de franck ont égalisé
ouvert sur le monde le meilleur vaccin
contre le repli national et ses démons
l'histoire du territoire est têtu et
français dont l'outre-mer ont confiance
dans la france quand la france c'est
leur faire confiance
aussi nous invitons le gouvernement à
agir vite et fort en faveur du
développement économique et océaniques
48 exposants 700 visiteurs de nombreux
secteurs d'activité et des conférenciers
de nombreux pays de la zone
ce salon se veut ainsi ambitieux dans
une économie de la connaissance et de
l'innovation où les skieurs sont nourris
tous les échelles ne sont plus les mêmes
elles ne sont surtout plus simplement
locale le numérique a fait tomber elle
est entière le changement peut sembler
brutale et les territoires ultramarins
ne doivent pas su c'est 8 à sion mais
promet les orienter à leur avantage vous
que à leur contact j'ai obligatoirement
le sourire moi qui souhaite voir les
territoires d'outre-mer connaître encore
davantage d'initiatives soutenir encore
davantage de jeunes dans la création
d'entreprise et puis faire que la france
dans ce bassin maritime rayonne bien sûr
l'afrique sur sur l'inde
sur l'asie donc après un discours
encourageant pour le monde économique
les gagnants d'un concours de création
dans le domaine de la santé ont été
récompensés je veux bien entendre
l'économie légale au moins sur le
développement durable
mais je pense que notre jeunesse a
besoin aussi de moyens puisque à
l'époque j'avais ma pioche et c'était
peu aujourd'hui la moindre petite
machine elle coûte
nous devons nous aujourd'hui même dans
l'économie frugal donner des moyens à
nos jeunes d'accéder aux machines qu'il
faut pour pouvoir au-delà de son cerveau
pouvoir faire rayonner j'allais dire sa
qualité son innovation avec une
signature créole la situation
géographique de notre île est
probablement l'une des solutions à la
grande tendance de l'économie frugal
[Musique]